hey leute und willkommen zu einer neuen
texture pack vorstellung diesmal die
zweite und zwar habe ich mir das texture
pack speedy kreft rausgesucht das wurde
mir mehrmals vorgeschlagen
es ist ein text gepäck was es schon sehr
lange gibt und ich habe gedacht 64er
variante bisschen langweilig deswegen
habe ich mit 256 air variante
runtergeladen
allerdings es hakt es ruckelt und so
weiter vor allem bei dieser map hier die
ja ziemlich viel beansprucht den
speicher deswegen würde ich sagen
wechseln wir das ganze mal ganz kurz auf
das 64 nur mal um euch ganz kurz zu
zeigen dass es davon echt mehrere
versionen gibt es gibt 16 32 64 128 256
und 512 glaube ich aber 512 klappt bei
mir so nicht mal also das touch pack
tier schon sehr comic ähnlich gehalten
die texturen und so weiter sind
natürlich auch auf den 60er stufe immer
noch recht angenehm anzuschauen
aber ich finde allgemein sieht alles ein
bisschen gezeichnet aus ein bisschen die
kanten schon sehr hart also sage ich mal
jetzt nicht so realitätsnah sondern mehr
wirklicher wie ich schon sagte comic
zeichentrick ähnlich hier die tiere
schon mal an du blödes ding du hier die
tiere den auch ziemlich witzig autos
läuft das hier so egal jedenfalls ist
halt wirklich alles comic mäßig gehalten
auch das bett und so und was man auch
gut sehen kann ist bei stein moment da
warstein womit moment moment also ich
bin es gab im creative mord aber wenn
ihr im survival mode zeit wenn man den
abort kommt er auch so ein komisches
gitters auch komik mäßig gehalten ist
mit so komischen zacken also jetzt nicht
unbedingt ganz ganz realitätsnah aber
auf jeden fall comic ähnlich mit
bettercall sieht das ganze dann noch mal
ein stück besser aus habe ich jetzt aber
gerade nicht drin
beziehungsweise gerade nicht rein
gemacht und deswegen sind die kanten da
so aus tiere allgemein team nicht sehr
gut gelungen und was ich auch witzig
finde ist zum beispiel äpfel und fackeln
wie schon gesagt alles comic ähnlich
gehalten aber was ich am geilsten finden
texture pack sind die ganzen werkzeug im
moment ich bin gerade noch in der
version 1.2 punkt 5 weil für die anderen
versionen der shader noch nicht da noch
nicht außen ist hier zum beispiel das
diamant schwert und so ich finde die
texturen einfach extrem geil die werden
zum beispiel auch bei an die boj
glaublich verwendet
und sogar dieser kleinen teile sind auch
nicht eingehalten und gehalten also die
exporte sondern diesen auch eklig aber
diese dinger hier die finde ich einfach
so geil ich weiß nicht warum aber ich
finde ich einfach auch ja wegen diesem
comic style recht interessant und was
man auch schon sieht ist dass die
schaufel hier unten im inventar falsch
rumgedreht ist also 90 grad nach in den
westen gedreht sage ich mal das ist
einfach weil wenn man dann was ab ob sie
das wirklich so aus als wird man das bag
hacken und nicht wie bei einer
spitzhacke dass man das wirklich einfach
so wegsteckt das dann einfach weg geht
sage ich mal also ist auf jeden fall
schon ganz cool jetzt gerade geht doch
gerade jetzt gerade geht auch gerade
auch gut also jetzt gerade jedoch die
sonne unter also man kann dann auch
sehen wie sich das ganze hier verändert
wenn man wenn quasi die nacht anbricht
und ich finde dieses texture pack ist
besonders dafür geeignet wenn man da
irgendwie fiel in einer höhle ist viel
rum spielt mit irgendwelchen zombies
weil die mode sehen echt total geil aus
und für redstone sachen her kann man
auch verwenden aber ich finde das sieht
jetzt nicht so unglaublich toll aus und
welchen redstone da sollte man lieber
aus die die texte pack verwenden welches
in der ich schon mal gezeigt hat in der
bisherigen texture pack vorstellung die
vor der hier hochgeladen wurde dies
unten in die video antworten verlinkt
mond uns alles wie ihr schon sieht okay
es ein halbmond aber auch eklig gehalten
ich gehe immer so rum
seht ihr auch schon also echt alles
eckig und naja das ist das texture pack
6 ppg kreft gibt es in ganz ganz vielen
version ich spiele gerade die 64er
variante kann ich euch nur empfehlen
läuft doch eigentlich ganz flüssig viele
hatten mich auch gefragt was wenn das
hier für eine map ist und das ist ganz
einfach eine download map also die wurde
erstellt die hab das ist kein stil
sondern schaut doch einfach mal in die
beschreibung dort findet ihr einen
download link zu dieser map einfach mal
vorbeischauen wenn ihr die auch spielen
wollte und da hinten sehen wir auch
schon die kripo als also sieht echt ganz
witzig aus und ich würde einfach sagen
wenn ihr das video gut findet gibt ihm
bitte einen daumen hoch wenn ihr es
scheiße fahndet bitte einen daumen
runter geben schreibt expertin die
kommentare die vielleicht als nächstes
vorstellen soll und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal tschüss sie